I have to personally work a little bit
hard at happiness like internally
interesting and so that manifests I
think outwardly so it's a conscious
choice you think that you're making
every day to be a happy person I wake up
I have to work like a little harder to
get to zero and then I like push it yeah
and then I push it a little past you
know it's interesting it's the probably
a lot of a lot of people might say it's
the last thing they would expect because
you have well first of all you brought
you've brought a lot of people a lot of
Happiness myself included thanks you've
done so much really funny work and I'm
going to tell a personal story which is
when you were shooting uh your Muppet
movie you did the sweetest thing I think
I ran into you somewhere on the Warner
Brothers a lot and no one had ever done
this for me before you said hey if you
like if you have any young kids which I
did uh come on by and watch me shoot a
scene and my kids were electrified and
you couldn't have been nicer about it oh
cool so you're a genuinely nice person